well I certainly thought he had a good
account of himself he looks confident
out there we know he's an ordinate Lee
understanding what it is he does that he
can do and we've seen him do it we know
he's capable of what if he really needs
to carry the whole load Jerry Jones
Cowboys no one is talking about rookie
running back Tony Pollard who had four
carries for 16 yards against the 49ers
on Saturday night not exactly the kind
of performance that cries out this guy
is ready to be the new Ezekiel Elliott
but look they they they've they've got
to do what they can Chris with what they
have while they wait for Zeke to come
back whether Tony Pollard Alfred Morris
whatever the move they make where we're
over two weeks in to this holdout right
there's no sense of urgency on either
side don't get the sense they're talking
that they're exchanging proposals that
anything is happening and who knows
what's going to ultimately happen but
the Cowboys are doing after I think
starting off in a very shaky way because
they didn't expect Elliott to hold out
they've done a nice job of reacting and
digging in any questions gonna become
who blinks yeah they're they're trying
to sell us and doing a pretty good job
that they think they're gonna be okay
but I'm still here to say that they're
not gonna be as good with Tony Palmer
that running back as they would with
Ezekiel Elliott again Tony Pollard
there's a lot of things I like I like
them come out of Memphis he does a
little everything I mean it really a lot
of his great place at Memphis were at
the wide receiver position Mike catching
wide receiver screens doing like doing
things like that make him plays down in
the field he's a slasher you know he
does have good speed he can make plays
happen all that but he is not a proven
Bell cow by any stretch of the
imagination and Ezekiel Elliott we know
that's his bread and butter
bread and butter when there's nothing
there and there's zero yards to be had
Ezekiel Elliot's gift is that he's
strong and powerful he lowers his
shoulder he lowers his head and he still
gets three yards when most running backs
would get zero and then you're in second
and seven and that's a lot better than
second and 10 and it's those little
things that I think are just gonna
continue to pop up where Cowboys coaches
and evaluators gonna realize they're
missing them Pollard I think we'll have
a nice place within this offense but
he's more almost like a Thor
down you know change a pace back to me
then the guy that you built this team to
be around which is sledgehammer
sledgehammer oh yeah and then he has
speed to break 50 and 60 yard runs that
guy's special and that guy deserves to
be paid like the highest paid running
back in football and they can say all
they want they're gonna miss Ezekiel
Elliott yeah and the question becomes
when does someone say okay we have to
work this out in 1993 it was after two
regular season games both of which the
Cowboys lost that the Emmitt Smith
holdout was resolved Sherine Williams
last week pointed out that was Emmitt
blinking not the Cowboys so I don't know
how much longer the Cowboys would have
done it but the Cowboys are looking at
this two ways long-term and as a
business and yes they want to win they
desperately want to get back to the
Super Bowl but they're not going to
upset their overall vision for how they
build their team by having one guy say I
want more than what they are willing to
pay him and they thought they were gonna
be able to wait till next year you know
what Chris I wonder whether at some
point they just say hey Zeke offers off
the table you're under contract for two
more years if you show up fine if you
don't find we're moving forward without
you and we'll see if it comes to that
and and you know we've been kicking
around ideas of players they could
acquire that would maybe make everyone
believe they're serious about it Shireen
mentioned last week LeSean McCoy they've
got a glut of running backs in Buffalo
yes they do the Cowboys decide hey Zeke
yet we got you on the books for three
and a half million what will welcome you
back whenever you show up until then we
got LeSean McCoy for this year now six
and a half million is a lot more than
they're gonna want to pay but if they
could work out some sort of a deal some
sort of a trade whether it's him whether
it's Adrian Peterson you know somebody
more than a rookie in Tony Pollard or an
Alfred Morris somebody that would make
us all say wow they're serious about
this idea I feel like that's the big
move that the Cowboys could make that
really would send a strong entire
message to Z that would send a huge
message that would mean that they're
ready they're prepared to go in the
season and play the season without him
that's that would be big time and I'm
not sure that that wouldn't piss Ezekiel
Elliott off even more to now then he
goes all right you got your running back
trade me do something get rid of me so I
don't know if that's gonna be the best
way to mend those
the other thing I want to ask you this
mic cuz I wasn't on the show last week
do you believe like what Stephen Jones
tried to say with Le'Veon Bell reset the
running back market you and I never got
discusses I don't think that's true I
understand you take him to it account
but I don't think he reset the market
with what levy on bail did well and I
think it's it's - in any negotiation
once you cross a bridge you can't come
back Stephen Jones had already said the
Todd Girly's deal is the starting point
for Ezekiel Elliott yeah you can't then
say it's not yeah oh well lady on bail
was a free agent he was unrestricted
there was no draft pick compensation and
that's what he got on the market so
that's what the market bears no Todd
Gurley still got more and Todd Gurley
got his from his team after three years
of of high-level service it is far
easier to draw parallels yes to Todd
Gurley and it is to lay beyond bail and
also later on bail has five years of
wear and tear and you could argue he's
got less tread on the tires going to
where right right yeah exactly
all those factors considered yeah I I
think that Ezekiel eight situation is
closer to Todd Gurley so I don't buy
that right but this is what the cowboys
are trying to do they're trying to pay
less and they're putting any argument
they can out there we'll be back with
more right after this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports